هل الصراع التكنولوجي حول العالم بدا يدخل
منعطفا جديدا فالجدل المثار مؤخرا حول
تطبيق تيك توك الصيني وحمله الحظر التي
تعرض لها في الكثير من البلدان الغربيه
فتح النقاش على الابعاد الحقيقيه وراء هذه
الحمله هذا ما تطرقت اليه صحيفه وستريت
جورنال الامريكيه التي اعتبرت ان الدول
باتت مدعوه الان الى الالتفات اكثر الى ما
اسمتها دبلوماسيه التطبيقات سباق تفوق في
مجال التطبيقات وجودتها وخصوصا انتشارها
لم يعد يقل اهميه عن اي تفوق تكنولوجي او
صناعي حقيقه دفعت الصين منذ سنوات للبحث
عن الرياضه في البرمجيات وخدمات الذكاء
الاصطناعي كما ان ما تقوم به الولايات
المتحده وبعض الدول الغربيه تجاه تيك توك
حاليا سلكته الصين منذ زمن طويل حين حضرت
العديد من التطبيقات من الولايات المتحده
ودول اخرى ونجاح تيك توك ليس الا ثمره
مجهودات الصين في هذا الباب
ويتوفر التطبيق حاليا على مليار وثمانمائه
مليون مستخدم في جميع انحاء العالم وذلك
بعد سبع سنوات فقط من انشائه ما يعكس
الفائده التجاريه والسياسيه ايضا التي
تحققها الصين من هذا الانتشار والتي من
شانها ان تقلق منافسيها الاكثر من ذلك هو
ان توجه الصيني الامريكي بحذر تطبيقات
الدول المنافسه سياسيا او اقتصاديا قد
يؤدي الى تقسيم دول العالم الى مجالين
تقنيين احدهما متحالف مع الولايات المتحده
والاخر يحتضن التكنولوجيا الصينيه واذا
كانت تهمه المواجهه لتيك توك هي التجسس
فان الدوره قد ياتي على تطبيقات صينيه
اخرى لكن بتهم مختلفه مثل تطبيقات
لن يقتصر على واشنطن وبيكين فحسب بل ان
هناك صراعا مشابها سيبرز بين دول مختلفه
اما لخلافات سياسيه او الاعتبارات
اقتصاديه وهو ما ينذر بعهد جديد من الصراع
التكنولوجي عنوانه التطبيقات وسما الذهبي
العربيه